the new Colossus is a direct sequel it
picks up immediately where the last one
left off new players will catch up
quickly and get what the game is about
but for returning players of course they
will know all of the backstory and
they'll just be able to flow right into
the narrative of this game they're
looking for you
even though v-day is severely injured
you never bacon mentally Vijay is about
us
he is very easy to identify with because
he has very primitive motives Vidya is
the strong quiet guy blue-collar guy
that gets things done he is an angry
angry man who has no power luck in his
life he is setting out to save the world
the sole focus is to kill the office and
the great camera DJ an honest
relationship is also evolving they're
about to become parents she's pregnant
you've gotten so bad it says we're
having twins so they're not just
fighting for themselves they're fighting
for a future where the coming
generations and live free and I'll be
damned if I'm gonna raise them in a
world rumpot eat Nazi at home we have
all in these characters that are all
coming back and they can blossom in this
story and one of them is from Engel she
has a beef with PJ
[Music]
laughs which is an icon of the
resistance
they can't have him running around they
call in terribili so she has a personal
vendetta and she really has a mission to
take him out but we also have these new
characters that you know already trying
to fight Nazis in America they're trying
to hold her own fort we've been in
Europe we've seen what happened now
we're taking to America and you get to
see that brutal Nazi version of the
American diner of the parade and it's
such a fun theme to explore close as a
developer and a player now you show me
your identification papers please I
think what's interesting about America
is the setting is that it's the country
very much founded on the idea of freedom
so to have that be under totalitarian
control it's a very interesting
juxtaposition the new Colossus takes
place in 1961 but it's not like the
1960s that we have in the real world
technology and advanced at an incredible
rate meaning that primarily the Nazis
but also of course the resistance have
access to technology that it's basically
a futuristic I'm not saying it's space
aliens right but it goes without saying
it's [ __ ] space aliens what I love
about making Wolfenstein games is that
we've been given this amazing freedom to
do things that are absolutely fearless
from a story perspective but we get to
do it in a way where you as a player can
be a hundred percent invested and be
respected we're not dumbing things down
I mean we do a lot of dumb things but
that's because they're fun
it's never done in a way that's
disrespectful to the world or the
environment or the characters or the
player we feel like this is the best
story that we've ever met
you